[Music]
so screen time I think a lot of people
do different things on their screens at
this point so it is a little bit of a
traditional point of hey too much screen
time is bad for you because at least for
people my age you think of that meaning
too much TV so it's about there being
choice and control of what that screen
time is so are you playing games are you
watching content are you creating stuff
are you you know is it a passive
experience as an active experience when
things work best you're also able to
connect the digital to the physical so I
think that there's a large gray area now
between too much screen time it just
needs to be defined a bit better as do
you mean too much of a passive watching
experience or do you mean the ability to
do a lot of different things to be
empowered to create to be given tools
for creative expression to be
problem-solving and collaborative while
being entertained I think in if it's
that latter you'd find people saying
right at the age we serve which is
generally 6 plus that there's I think
more good than bad if in fact it's an
active immersive experience as opposed
to a one-way passive experience we call
them florals so yeah we've done a lot of
generational researches and overall for
a returner and that was the term that I
guess we collectively obviously Time
Warner's an organization had coined very
early on before they were called
Generation Z which I think in fairness
is a little less descriptive and it just
comes from you know hey we were
Generation Y we were Generation X so you
just go down the alphabet but a lot of
people have different names plurals
because of the plurality of the way they
consume content and everything they do
it really
if Millennials needed lists because they
didn't come of age truly the information
revolution was happening around them and
they needed help filters sorting things
out this generation doesn't they are
really comfortable with choice and they
actually want to control it and if you
don't move quick enough for them like
Thomas Friedman thank you for being late
if you don't move quick enough for them
they just move on to the next thing
because they really they realize that
they have a whole lot of choice and they
want to control that so I think the
plurality of everything available to
them is more indicative than just the
letter so Cartoon Network focuses really
on creative confidence and this core
belief that we have an obligation to
raise the next generation of creators
makers and innovators so if you believe
that there was an industrial revolution
and information revolution we believe
that the next one is all about
creativity that you know if there was a
time where people would refer to geeks
inheriting the earth well I think the
whole brain thinkers and the creative
folks will really be the ones that
supercharge innovation in the future and
making sure that kids know that if you
learn things like coding and computer
science that it doesn't just mean
engineer or programmer but it can mean
animator video game developer it can
mean learning skills for self-expression
that will help you through the rest of
your life I grew up
Generation X over here I grew up and I
was always told that team sports really
helped you in the future so that it
built better leaders it helped you with
working in a larger team if you believe
that and there's definitely some truth
to it but if you apply that to things
like coding and giving kids creative
tools to learn self-expression that
ability to solve problems to work
collaboratively to create and make will
serve them and ready them for anything
that comes next not just necessarily to
hey be an animator so I think that's the
if you want to change the world you
start with kids because everything else
is iterative if you really buy into that
I think that's the higher thinking
reason why to do it
on the flip side of the commercial
reason why to do it I would say is they
expect it from us you know at the
earliest stages they're starting
to again learn to swipe before anything
else learning to participate in their
media whether it means they go and they
play Minecraft and they start to add to
that building or they want to play games
that allow them to you know draw
whiskers on things or pretty ears on
things they expect there to be some
amount of giving get and us meeting
their expectations is core to what we do
our job is to to serve audiences that
are growing up mobile like plurals or
generation Z everybody seems to have as
many names for them as screens they use
quite frankly so they expect things to
be mobile it's all they've ever known so
making sure that we can meet to exceed
the expectations of this audience who
want choice and control expects things
to be very visual in nature a lot of
that feeds into how we think about
creating content from inception to
create content and experiences that puts
them at the forefront has to reflect
them so a lot of the ways we find our
way into that sweet spot between
creativity and technology is by
reflecting our audience and then of
course we want to do right by them both
in the day to day and sort of in a big
way
[Music]